watch
this is not a quadratic is it
at least not in its current form but i
can make it a quadratic okay
let's see this denominator i'm going to
multiply it across okay i'm going to get
this
do you agree with that i've just
multiplied that denominator and there's
a y on the left hand side so this is y
times everything on my denominator you
okay with that
and that's equal to this
okay it's all i've done
by the way it's never equal to zero that
denominator it's never equal to zero so
i can multiply by that like i won't
break anything okay
now this
this is a quadratic it's a quadratic
isn't it i just need to shuffle it
around a little bit okay uh let's get it
into general form shall we get into
general form because general form is
kind of what we need to do all this
stuff
uh we'll put all of the terms on one
side because general form has a zero on
the right hand side right okay so i'm
going to get this
let's think about it
x squared
minus y x squared i'm putting all of
these guys over here and i'm just going
to write zero on the right hand side
uh
minus 2x
minus 2yx
plus 4
minus 4y
you created that
i took everything on the left hand side
away from the right hand side and then i
just switched it around because that's
usually the way i write general form
okay
it's messy it's messy but i can see the
quadratic underneath there one more step
here are the x squareds
here are the x's
and here is the constant term
so all i need to do is factorize and
then i'll see it's an ax squared plus bx
plus c just like every other quadratic
out there okay
what's the a in this case it factorizes
out okay i'm going to get 1 minus y
do you see that
once i've factorized x squared that's
how many x squares i have okay
how many x's do i have uh this is a bit
messy okay i'm gonna do
i'm gonna do it like this plus
minus two minus two y
you okay with that i'm just very
watchful for my science it's really easy
to get confused with sides here
and then just for the heck of it i'm
just going to put brackets around this
so you can see that's
c
is that right
it's ax squared
plus bx
plus c
it's just a quadratic it looks weird
because there are y's in there but it's
fine it's okay actually i want y's to be
in there that's exactly what i want
because that's what i'm trying to solve
for i'm trying to find some restriction
on why because i know there must be i
just don't know where it is okay
all right so
what do i do from here i want the
discriminant
which is this thing under here which you
guys know it's b squared
b squared minus four a c i want it to be
greater than or equal to zero greater
than or equal to zero okay so let's give
this a go what is the discriminant it's
uh minus two minus 2y squared there's b
squared
minus 4
a
c
there's the discriminant boy it looks
like a mess okay but be patient with it
we can work with this okay we want it to
be greater than or equal to zero so that
i get real solutions for x because i
know i get real solutions for x okay i
have to
so now i unfurl this thing okay now you
could just sort of brute force it i'll
save you a bit of time because my
emphasis here is not algebra like i
don't wanna i'm you guys can solve
algebra okay so you can simplify this i
will show you what you end up getting
you get this guy
if you do your algebra right
that's what you end up with
okay
um i could flip around my signs a little
bit as well i'll make that a
minus
and i'll make that a plus
okay and that means i'm going to be less
than zero
okay
i did like five steps there okay so if
you're gonna be confused that's okay
just do it out you'll see that you will
arrive at this point and the inequality
must switch around because i want
something positive okay it's just easier
to deal with trust me that you'll get
there you have to factorize this guy
it's not especially nice but it can be
done you should get this
three y minus one
y minus three
from memory okay let me check
yeah cool okay
so therefore where are the solutions to
this a third
a third
and three
right a third
and three that's where your solutions
are
so that
is where your range is
let me say that one more time because
it's such a big deal okay when you solve
this quadratic
you factorize
okay
and then it's going to be all right he's
between a third and three those are the
numbers